the un secretary general has for weeks
said he thinks war can be avoided but
his warnings about the situation are
getting more dire
with the concentration of russian forces
around ukraine
i am deeply concerned about heightened
tensions and increased speculation about
a military conflict in europe
i still think
it will not happen
but if it did
it would be catastrophic
sitting with the german foreign minister
annalina berbach the u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken was again asked
about the prospect of war the
differences have to be resolved through
dialogue through diplomacy
we are deeply concerned that that is not
the path that russia has embarked on
the mayor of kiev vitali klisko was in
the audience
we're ready to fight
we're ready to defend our families
our states
our cities
our citizens
we need support
a point clearly aimed at germany which
has not been supplying weapons to
ukraine a position the foreign minister
said was based on her country's history
our responsibility after the second
world war was
that never again from germany there will
be war and never again there will be
genocide
the discussion was moderated by the
incoming chairman of the munich security
conference christoph hoyesgun is his
country's former ambassador to the un
and was chancellor merkel's foreign
policy advisor
ambassador the big question is there
going to be a war
i think nobody knows
i don't know if putin himself knows he's
plain he's playing his games he's one
day saying that now we want to um we
want to go into negotiations he says
there was never um
any um you know we never had any
intentions
and then you are following right now
that um when you look at um the donbass
you see that the number of ceasefire
violations is skyrocketing
on saturday here in munich the british
prime minister flies in the u.s vice
president and the ukrainian president
are supposed to speak and there'll be a
meeting of the g7 foreign ministers on
this growing crisis james bay's al
jazeera munich